Welcome to the stream.
Welcome!
Can I talk?
Yes, you can.
I have a mouth.
Good, good.
I can do it.
Open your mouth.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello.
Master.
Lady.
Mint.
Good morning.
Everybody, please say hello to Ayami-sensei.
Hello.
Say hello.
You need my introduction?
Yes, please introduce yourself.
Oh, okay.
I studied English yesterday.
Okay.
Let's do it.
Hi, hi, hi.
Everyone, hi.
My name is Ayami.
Yes, Ayami.
I'm an illustrator.
And I'm a YouTuber.
Yes, you know me.
Yes.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for giving me this collaboration.
Thank you for inviting me.
And my hobby...
Social distance.
Please, social distance.
Yes, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
And my hobby is stocking mint.
Twitter and stream.
And my favorite type of girl is...
Yes, mint.
Yes, yes, yes.
And I'm not good at English.
Sorry, sorry.
But try using English today.
Yoroshiku onegaishimasu.
I'm good.
How about my English?
Oh, my God.
Perfect.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
I heard sometimes, oh, one years old English.
I'm sorry.
Oh, thank you.
But that's charm point.
Charm point.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Charming Ayami.
Okay, thank you.
Yes.
So, this weekend, Ayami-sensei will be coming to America.
America.
Where is America?
Too far.
You can swim.
Tired.
Because I'm 2100 years old, and I cannot swim.
Using plane, flight.
Oh, okay.
Too far.
But, but, but, but.
I can swim.
I have been to Hawaii, family trip.
But I have never been to the real United States.
Are you nervous?
What is real USA?
Real USA.
Today we will learn real USA.
USA.
Is there a real USA?
Do you live in the United States?
I don't think so.
Is it only the news?
Yes.
It's like an AI video.
I see.
What should I do?
I'm scared.
Mint, do you really stay in America?
Where are you?
Me?
I'm in America.
Real America.
You are in Japan, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Because when Ayami contact to you and message, I think you always...
Sorry.
I'm now in Japan.
You always stay.
Again?
Again in Japan?
Let's play.
Again.
In the next month.
That's right.
Welcome.
Welcome to Japan.
Let's play.
Let's hang out.
I was thinking that Mint doesn't live in America.
I think you live in Japan almost.
My feeling is that.
And you live in my heart.
Yes.
I love you.
I live in your closet.
I'm scared.
You are scared?
Are you scared?
I was surprised.
Wow.
Oh, that's right.
Because you are a ghost.
I'm always close.
I understand.
You are a ghost.
Yes, yes, yes.
Scary.
I'm a scary ghost.
No, no, no.
If you feel cold, I...
It's me.
I heard that some movie.
Oh.
Some movie and under the bed and getting cold.
Yeah.
That is... Me!
That is...
Oh, that's what it is.
Okay, I understand.
That's what it is.
Okay, okay.
Oh, you guys every time so cold.
I think because me too always beside you.
That's what it is.
Heat tech.
Wearing heat tech.
But in summer, it's so great.
Yeah, yeah.
Really?
Hot?
Already hot?
Yeah, if it's hot, I can make you cool.
Oh.
Oh, then really good.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
How about winter?
Oh.
It's okay.
Sometimes it's like eating ice cream in winter.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I understand.
Yeah.
Ice cream is always good.
Hold the time.
Hot time.
Every time is good.
That is you.
Okay, I understand.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
This is our first.
Oh, yeah.
Our first collaboration.
Our first stream.
But my feeling is something weird because we, we, we, we two close.
Really?
I think it's normal, maybe.
Yeah.
Do you know do you know the word deja vu?
Ah, deja vu.
Deja vu, yes.
Yes, I know.
I talked to you first time.
I want to collaboration with you.
That time I mean saying to you I want to playing that game.
That is almost deja vu, isn't it?
Deja vu.
Oh, yes.
It's a good English deja vu.
Maybe we should play game next time.
Okay.
Something scary but yes, we can do it.
Something scary?
Yeah.
Because I'm not good at game, playing game.
Ah.
And I saw you last two stream?
You playing six hour?
Are you okay?
But it's normal.
It's normal.
Ah, okay.
Six hour, are you okay?
Oh, yes.
I understand.
Yeah, see, they say together strong.
Push, push.
Oh, really?
Your hand is so cold and I think you are not good controller, maybe.
What?
Freezing hand and not good controller and bad game.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nothing, nothing.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
You say I'm bad again?
Wait, what?
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
No, no, no, no.
No.
I don't know English.
Sorry, sorry.
I think you know.
I just love you forever.
Yeah, yeah.
Everyone, this time is my first visit.
Actually, our real America, real USA.
Yeah.
What is different?
USA and US, what is different?
Oh, same.
It's the same.
USA or the same?
And America is three is everything.
Three are same.
America, USA, US is same.
Yeah.
It's just a shorter.
Okay, I understand.
Sometimes because USA.
Okay, it's difficult.
Difficult English.
I know what that means.
United States of America.
As expected, a genius.
Genius, genius, genius.
Oh my god.
Let's do it differently.
Wow.
Great America.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm studying, yes.
Genius.
I'm visit real America first time.
Yeah.
You mean to, you have Have you ever been to Chicago?
I have.
Oh, really?
Yeah, I've gone to Anime Central.
Anime Central.
Yeah.
Already?
What time?
One time?
Two times?
Ten times?
No, no, no.
Maybe maybe only two times.
Oh, really?
Really?
How about that that that that event?
I want to know them mood.
Oh.
Many people, so hot.
So many people.
Oh.
Really?
Yeah.
So many.
I think I think maybe your space, your booth will have a line.
Line?
No, no, no.
Yes, yes, yes.
I think.
No, no, no.
No one coming.
No.
No, no, no.
Everybody?
I know because always YouTube comments and Twitter, everyone saying I will go your space.
I will go to your booth.
But no one coming.
Eh?
No way.
No one coming.
Really?
It's cold.
Too cold.
But even at Comiket, your line was so long.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I mean, that time I mean, find, found meet that line.
I'm really shocked because I saw line and Oh, who is it?
Who is she?
Eh?
I know her.
Why?
Why you standing line?
Because I want to be a normal fan.
Oh, I know, I know, but, but, but, you, you, you, Mint, I know you, you are my fan.
That is really happy, but I think, I mean, always think about, I mean, and Mint is friend and I want just you you work my space, work in my space, and, hi, Ayami, that is my dream.
Why you always standing and waiting?
I, I mean, really, I mean, really, that time, I mean, really feeling so long distance.
Eh, really?
Mint, if Mint don't think about we are friends, maybe, and she waiting forever, and I mean, I'm already worried and sad, and, and I'm, I'm really worried, because, because, because, my worried is reason is you waiting in, in, in that line, I think some people definitely know you,
know you, definitely, definitely, absolutely, every, the line people, oh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, Mint, Mint here, Mint, Mint here, oh, yeah, my, and my friends, my illustration friends, and my virtual friends, they are confused, because, you so cute,
and my friends want to cheating on you.
Eh?
Wow, really cute.
Oh, cheating, go, go cheating!
Go, go!
I, I, I don't want I want you to wait in line, please.
Please, next time, please.
Don't do that.
Don't, don't, okay.
Don't do that, please.
Maybe the fans think it's rude if I walk...
If I don't wait.
If I walk...
Hi, Ayami-sensei!
Who is it?
I think my comic staff think about...
Oh, Ayami have another country friend.
Wow.
Worldwide.
Ayami is popular all over the world.
That's right, that's right.
Oh!
Foreigners!
My staff think about that.
Oh, Ayami!
Really popular, maybe?
But...
America event is really first time and I'm really nervous because this Ayami bring my books and my posters and something something, but if they left, I think burn front of convention center.
Burning everything.
Burning!
Because too heavy, too heavy.
Campfire my goods and my books.
And I think that time more people come to my space.
Oh wow, what is that?
Campfire?
What is that?
Everyone interested in campfire.
Not my artist, Eri.
I think maybe not interested.
I think they'll be terrified.
I think...
Ah!
Fire!
And they'll run away.
Something weird Asian people in there.
She...
Burn... burning everything.
She's okay?
Everyone think...
Everyone...
I think another people say, Oh, she crazy.
Actually...
Sensei...
The...
Um...
Sensei...
The books you're bringing...
Bring?
Um...
I like it.
Aren't you too erotic?
Ah, that's...
Ah...
This time really...
This time I'm studying U.S.A.
Law.
L.A.W.
Law because I don't want arrest.
Am I drawing to read and if... well maybe I'm arrest.
And I'm really scary.
I'm really scary.
And this time display illustration is my manager saying pure illustration.
He's saying that.
And I'm choosing my illustrations.
And first time I'm sending 10 illustrations.
And my manager saying please pure illustration.
Please select.
Pure illustration.
You're wrong.
Ayami wrong.
Your brain suck.
Wake up!
And I'm sending again another 10 10 illustrations.
And my manager give up Ayami and he choosing my illustrations.
And please please send PSD file.
I mean 3 times this time I'm selecting my pure illustration and I'm really shocked because I think I think my illustration is not to read.
I think.
Really?
And this right now poster is all pure illustration.
All?
Poster?
Poster is all pure.
That's right.
Comparing to the left I think my cover illustration my book cover illustration is something danger but but poster is I think that is pure I think that is 5 years old buying is okay.
But my book please take your ID card.
I'm checking your age.
You 20?
Okay.
What year is okay?
18?
I'm studying.
18 is
university.
University?
College.
College people?
Okay.
I'm checking your ID.
Bring your ID.
She'll check your address.
She stalk you.
Address in there?
Yes.
I want to know good address some rich people rich people address I want to I mean remember that and some guy's good address I mean, would you marry me?
Would you marry me?
I want to live USA forever please.
So boyfriends if you if you are rich good address then leave your address.
with Ayami-sensei Okay.
Thank you.
I need fast internet please.
Isn't it fast in Japan?
Yeah, but I don't know.
How about USA internet?
It's good?
It depends on where.
Sometimes it's slow.
Sorry.
Japan too.
Internet...
It's slower.
It's slower than Japan.
But...
I don't know.
Maybe not America.
Hi.
Yes.
That's scary.
And you?
Yeah.
I mean I I Please Please tell me about something you must eat or experience in the US or Chicago.
What is good?
I want to I want to buy I want to buy I want to buy gun.
Okay.
That is my dream.
I want a gun.
I'll show you where to go buy a gun.
Can I buy?
I really want a gun.
Please marry me.
Please marry me everyone.
I want a gun.
Oh my god.
I want a gun really.
It's okay.
Sorry.
Because my head my brain, my thinking is America is freedom and gun.
It's true.
Oh yeah.
I saw news sometimes.
The topic is some freedom thing.
The topic or a gun.
I'm really curious gun.
But I mean one time just one time shoot Oh.
Range?
Yes.
A small gun.
I've never done that.
Oh really?
I need shotgun.
Shotgun?
Oh my god.
Shotgun and I want hunting power.
Who marry Ayami?
You're already American I think.
You're already American.
She's hunting boars you guys.
I'm really happy.
I mean talk to everyone and talk to Mint.
This time I mean go to Chicago.
But truly I think I mean go to Texas maybe.
I mean buy guns maybe.
At the booth you can have left side left side book right side poster middle marriage certificate
Good idea.
I love it.
It can be an auction.
Oh.
Really good idea.
I will try.
Like something movie I saw movie some How?
Where was it?
Like Las Vegas.
Las Vegas.
Drinking alcohol and marry and divorce?
In Las Vegas you can get married very quickly.
When I meet child time I saw American movie and I think about wow really amazing.
Wow so fast.
Wow that is real freedom.
Eat it.
Okay next convention not Chicago.
Go to Las Vegas.
Las Vegas?
That is good idea.
No no no.
But I really want to go first.
Next is Texas.
Texas has no event isn't it?
No they have event.
They have event?
Yeah.
Really?
And that event everyone bring their gun.
No no no.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I think everyone's inside pocket inside pocket everyone have has gun isn't it?
Gun or food.
Food?
Hotdog?
Okay I see.
I see.
Can I see this?
Excuse me.
Hi.
Please tell me.
What is good?
What is good food or some experience?
Please recommend.
In Chicago In Chicago maybe pizza.
It's a deep deep dish.
Deep dish.
Oh hotdogs.
Yeah hotdogs.
Yeah.
Deep dish pizza is yummy?
Really yummy?
Everyone saying yummy.
Really yummy.
This is really yummy.
I think I have never eaten it.
Mint.
How dare you?
You really bad girl.
I have eaten it in Japan.
What?
Don't lie to me.
Sorry.
Really?
So what did you eat in Chicago?
What did you eat in Chicago?
What did I eat?
I went to an event near an event in a German restaurant.
There was a German restaurant close to the convention center where we went.
And there was a sausage.
Hakusen?
Some meat?
They dance on the tables.
Why?
I don't know.
Dance everyone or?
You dancing too?
No.
Why?
You like dancing.
Sometimes.
Before the stream we talk about your dancing.
Really good.
I really like your dancing.
No.
Too cute.
I love you forever.
This time.
You.
You dancing.
Minto.
You are not dancing stream yet?
No.
I have no 3D.
Oh.
Make it.
Can I borrow?
I can borrow my modem.
I become inside Ayami-sensei.
Push.
Oh my god.
Wow.
It's so big.
Heavy.
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
But your...
Your...
Your boobs are good size.
Now.
Really?
Really good.
A little smaller.
It's fake size.
It's a good bra.
Oh.
I see.
I understand.
How amazing bra.
That...
You buying that.
Your bra.
In America or where you buying?
In America.
The fake size.
Yeah.
I want to buy two same things.
Okay.
You don't need it.
I think.
I want.
I need.
Because I want more more bigger.
Oh.
But Minto you know.
I'm 100 years old human.
And...
My oppai.
Wrong.
Not big.
Just wrong.
That's okay.
I think.
I think maybe also.
Boyfriend loves that too.
Boyfriends love that too.
Boyfriend you like that too, right?
Thank you.
Long boob?
Long boob is good.
How long is okay?
Really long.
Maybe.
Almost to my knee.
They reach.
Almost to my knees.
I can't tell.
You have a really good bra.
Yes.
This time I'm shopping my bra.
I learned something new.
And pizza.
Pizza.
Pizza and.
The German food and.
I really want to know.
You tried and.
Really eat.
Eat food.
I want to know.
What is good.
What?
You.
You are mean.
Mean.
What?
Hot dog.
BBQ.
What is BBQ?
Something like steak?
Steak and pork.
Ah.
Chicken BBQ.
That's it.
Plates and everything in one plate.
Yes.
That's good.
Smoked meat.
That's BBQ.
Tacos.
Mexican food.
Mexican food in America is totally different from Japanese food in Japan.
Really?
How about Taco Bell?
Taco Bell is the same.
It's the same.
It's different from Taco Bell, right?
It's different.
What is different?
Smell or taste or size.
Taste.
Taste?
More deep or something different taste?
Maybe real Mexican food is better.
Real?
Real.
Taco Bell is real.
Not real.
But America is not Mexico.
Just nearby.
Near?
How?
Guys, how people can eat real Mexican food?
Ah.
Mmm.
Maybe not Taco Bell.
If it's not Taco Bell, it's okay maybe.
Okay.
Taco Bell.
Taco Bell yummy.
Yummy.
Go to Mexico.
You can have it.
That is good idea.
Mexico.
Okay, I understand.
Sometimes I'm watching American TV show.
I think that time.
I don't remember exactly.
I mean...
You know Dexter?
Dexter.
Dexter, you know?
The serial killer.
That guy.
That's why you think like...
Dexter.
Dexter co-workers.
I think.
I remember Mexican.
Mexican people.
Many.
And they using...
Mexico Spanish?
Oh yeah, Spanish.
And they saying...
Say to Dexter.
You studying...
Spanish.
So, it's about time.
You should study Spanish.
I talked to Dexter.
And then...
Somehow...
While I was eating Taco Bell.
While eating?
While eating...
I was like...
Is it like this?
I was thinking like...
I was thinking like that.
It's a little bit different.
My image of Mexican people is...
In...
Inside Dexter.
Too different.
Different?
Why different?
Sorry.
Can you speak Spanish?
Thank you.
Yeah.
Teacher.
I love you.
I love you too.
Preciosa Minto.
I love you.
I'm studying a little and...
Now I remember Preciosa.
And...
Gracias.
Nobio.
Because I talked to my boyfriend.
And Nobio.
I'm studying Dexter.
Mexican people is...
Different.
Maybe it's different.
I've never seen Dexter.
But I think maybe...
It's a little different.
Really?
Why no watching?
You ghost.
Everyone kill.
Everyone dead.
Inside the television.
Good.
Minto.
You saw.
You have been saw.
NCI.
NCIS.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Really?
Yeah, I've seen.
I've seen.
I mean...
I mean like...
Gips.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah.
Because I'm 100 years old.
And Gips is too young.
Demi.
I like a young guy.
And I like Gips.
I think...
It's a little...
Is your head okay?
But sometimes...
Sometimes...
I mean...
Watching that...
Some teenagers...
Something...
Rumor...
Rumor.
Some high school story.
And some...
Why she dead.
Gossip girl?
No, no, no.
No.
Rumor.
High teen drama.
13 Reasons Why.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry.
English.
Sorry, sorry.
Different title.
I've seen it too.
Yes, yes, yes.
You saw that?
Yes.
Too sad story.
Yeah, so sad.
Yeah, I mean...
Saw that.
I mean...
Feeling is some...
Complicated because...
I mean, cannot understand teenager.
Because I'm 100.
What are...
What they are... something, something.
I got really shocked.
Too young.
This is American TV show?
I think so.
Oh, I think so.
Do you watch a lot of American TV show?
Hmm...
Sometimes because...
My parents think about...
When I'm watching some English TV show.
They... my parents think about...
Oh!
I am studying.
They think about...
Oh!
I'm studying.
Oh, good girl, good girl.
Oh, yes, yes.
And I mean always...
Watching...
The Conan show.
And SNL...
Something, something and...
I mean always...
Oh, yes, yes.
I'm studying English.
Studying English.
Oh my god.
Good student.
No, no, no.
I mean always...
Studying something...
Bad word.
You don't know any bad words.
You're pure sensei.
Yeah, yeah, I'm pure.
I'm pure, really.
I'm pure because...
I...
I never say...
Someone, to someone.
Like some F word.
Because...
I mean never been Google America.
And I...
I mean no chance.
Saying to...
Say F word.
Oh!
You can say it now.
Not?
Yeah.
One more time, one more time.
Can I say it properly?
How about this?
Is it correct?
Yeah, it's powerful.
Sorry, sorry.
I like you.
Just mean to hate you guys.
No!
I love you, yes.
Before the stream, when you guys were crying...
Don't cry.
Yeah, we were talking about it.
Yeah, but...
I mean...
Think about...
Mean to tsundere.
No, no, no.
No, I mean just tsundere.
Don't worry.
Mean to always love you guys.
I don't know.
No.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, true, true, true.
So...
Tacos.
No, snack.
Snack?
Like potato chip.
Do you have something you like?
Something you eat a lot?
Yeah, like...
Mint chan doesn't like...
carbonated drinks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so...
Carbonation?
Yeah, yeah.
Orange, what do you eat?
No soup.
I want to eat something...
Dirty things.
Dirty.
Dirty, salty.
High calorie.
Do you know...
Kettle chips?
Yeah, yeah.
What make?
I don't know.
Kettle chips.
Kettle chips?
What?
Kettle chip is kind of...
potato chip?
Yes.
Yeah, kind of potato chip.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're a little more crunchy.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah.
I like crunchy.
They're so yummy.
Cooked in a kettle.
How taste is good?
Something salt, bacon, something.
Honey, something.
Have you tried sea salt and vinegar?
Yes.
Yes, I tried that using lace.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is so yummy.
Almost similar taste.
And crunchy.
This taste is same.
But crunchy is...
You should go to...
You should see if they will take you to...
Target.
Ah, Target.
I think about...
going to send a box to me.
Okay, I'll send a box.
I'll send you.
Okay, okay.
So sweet, yes, yes.
You...
I think because...
Ah...
How should I say?
I will send you to a hotel.
Thank you, Mint-chan.
I imagined this.
If you go to Target...
Go to Target!
I can buy!
I know Target.
Yes, I have money.
Yes, I have credit card.
Yes, I can buy.
Yes, I can buy myself.
No, I'll buy for you.
No, no, it's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can.
I just need some money...
exchange.
This is too high.
Dollar is too high.
And it's very cheap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My dream is...
I mean exchange...
One dollar...
One dollar?
100 yen?
It's about 150 yen now.
150 yen?
Yes, yes, yes.
Because of Mint-chan...
I mean steal money.
Dollar.
Mint wallet and...
I'm changing.
100 bucks.
And 10,000 yen.
10,000 yen.
Wow!
50% I got money!
Yes!
Yeah, I'm really happy that.
And I really want to that.
Okay.
You don't have to steal.
I'll give you my money.
Oh, really?
How many?
How many money you can?
I don't know.
However...
Maybe...
1,000?
In my wallet, I have...
1,000,000?
3 dollars.
Hey guys!
Good luck!
You guys, what are you doing?
Mint have just 3 dollars.
What?
What happened?
You guys!
Go, go!
Spend money!
No, they're saving the money for you at Anime Central.
Is that so?
If so, it can't be helped.
Don't use money!
Money!
Bring money to my space!
Don't super chat!
It's terrible, isn't it?
I think every guy...
Ayami is crazy.
No, they love you.
Right, everybody?
Say yes.
I'm waiting, yes.
Is there anything you want to do in America?
Uh...
Ah!
I really want to go to their Chicago Art Museum.
Oh!
I really want to go there and I want to see that GoFu.
GoFu?
GoFu!
GoFu.
No, it's not!
GoFu?
Don't say super chat!
Oh my god!
Vincent Van Gogh.
What?
Oh!
Van Gogh!
Not Van.
Van Gogh.
English.
English is difficult.
Vincent Van Gogh.
Okay.
Vincent Van Gogh drawing his room picture in Chicago museum.
Oh, and I want to go to there and I will steal that.
And arrest.
I mean...
I mean live forever USA jail.
Happy life.
That's how you can live in America.
In jail.
Yeah, jail.
Too cold.
Maybe there is too cold.
Maybe?
Maybe, maybe.
In jail is too cold.
I think it's good.
That is not bad, I think.
Yeah.
Okay.
Meat.
We talk almost one hour.
I cannot believe.
Today's stream is what is good America food or something something.
That is not main main topic.
It's not the main.
Yeah.
Main topic.
What are you?
What are we doing?
I'm confused.
Everybody must see.
Look.
Everybody look at the drawing.
What Ayumi sensei is bringing to Anime Central.
Thank you.
Make sure you buy everything so she doesn't burn it in front of the convention.
Yeah.
Yes.
If you guys don't need a campfire, buy it.
Buy it, please.
Yes.
Yeah.
Please buy it.
Wait.
Yes.
Maybe.
Maybe this is a strange question.
Yes.
But out of these books.
Sensei, what is your recommendation?
Oh.
It's all nice.
Sensei.
That is really difficult question.
But this time, I make English version book.
Everything transferred that What is that?
Comment?
Yes.
Text, everything changed to English.
That is read book.
ID card.
Wow.
ID card check.
I mean drawing my original character, Mei.
And Mei do some reading.
And that book, I mean transfer English.
Wow.
I think that is recommend.
And second book is...
That is really sad story.
I don't want to talk about that.
But...
Just one weeks ago, I mean make new book.
Uh...
Memory.
Yeah.
My...
My witch's daughter book.
That is recommend too.
And...
Uh...
Recommend poster.
Yes.
Something that...
You are watching on the...
Uh...
Yes.
Green.
Green poster.
I mean recommend.
Ah...
Sorry.
I mean recommend everything.
Bye.
Thank you.
What?
I don't know.
Hurry up.
Um...
I want to know...
About you.
About me.
Yes.
I want to know...
Me too.
Everything.
Because...
You saying...
You saying your fans?
Maybe?
Not yet.
Not yet?
Really?
Yeah.
Uh...
Okay.
First...
Announcement.
Yeah.
In...
Mint channel.
Yes.
Yeah.
This time...
I mean...
Do live drawing in...
Anime... Animal...
Animal.
Anime...
Anime central.
I mean...
Do live...
Do live drawing...
Uh... session.
And... that time...
Uh... Ayami...
Drawing... uh...
Mint.
So if you're going to...
Anime central...
At the live drawing panel...
Ayami sensei...
Can I... can I drawing...
Mint?
Yes!
I'm about to cry.
I'm so happy.
Really?
And... and...
I really want to asking...
I heard I understand...
I understand you draw your concept...
Sketch?
Oh, yes.
Uh...
I want to know which part...
Is the...
Point?
Your design?
Okay.
Let's check.
Let's take a look.
Yes.
It's me!
Mint-chan!
Charm, what would the point be?
Mmm...
Your butt?
It's...
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Psycho.
I want to rick.
Can I rick?
Okay.
You can go.
Me too.
What kind of stream is this?
What is stream?
Please teach me.
Your everything.
Let's see.
Maybe...
Um... I have...
Um... my butt.
And...
Yeah.
Also...
On my socks...
Chocolate.
Right.
Melting chocolate.
Oh...
It's delicious.
Can I rick?
Yeah yeah.
La la la la la.
Shut up.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
What's streaming?
Okay, okay.
It's okay.
Please forgive me, YouTube.
We are pure.
Yeah.
Don't worry, YouTube.
Don't worry.
This is just... this is nice about introduction.
So just lick chocolate.
Yeah, yeah.
You can see... you can see my ribbon is also chocolate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Really cute.
How you think about this design?
You want to be made first time?
And I'm really curious you like mint choco?
Oh, I do.
But I don't know why I became mint choco.
At first, I was only mint.
And then I became mint choco.
I don't know why.
I
love you.
Mint choco.
About 100.
Are you 100 years old to eat mint choco?
That is too...
Too...
What is it?
Is it too stimulating?
Like...
Because...
It's a taste I've never eaten before.
It's like...
After all...
Is this okay?
Is it okay to eat this taste?
That's right.
When I was born, there was no elevator.
So...
Maybe it's too much for someone who is 100 years old.
Yeah.
Mint choco is too difficult to taste.
But...
Not...
Not dislike.
Just...
A little...
Not good?
Not good at?
Yeah, not good at?
Not...
Not good at?
Not good...
But...
Someone buying to me it.
Not paying my money.
But...
I can paying to you.
I love you.
Like this...
I'm really...
I mean first time saw your design.
I'm really shocked.
Oh.
Color.
Because mint color is I think really good color.
Because I mean never think about using mint color.
Really?
Using drawing.
I mean wow.
That is really funny and interesting.
This is an interesting color, I think.
This is a good mint.
Good mint.
Because I've never tried using that color.
This time I'm using mint color.
I'm really excited.
A lot of mint.
What?
You're choosing mint color?
Just you like mint?
Yes, I like mint.
My idol Oshi, her color was mint.
So I became mint.
Thank you, Oshi-san.
Thank you so much.
Cute Mint appeared as your idol.
Mint was born as your idol.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
So I want to know what's mint's favorite part.
What part is your favorite?
Or you like?
Which part do you like the most?
Your butt?
My butt?
Your butt again?
Your chest?
Your chest.
That's your idea.
I'm sorry.
Your butt.
Actually, I think my favorite part is my sleeves.
Sleeves?
Yes.
Do you like?
When you sleep in time, the sleeves...
You can watch it or not.
If you can't see it, you can do it like this.
Like this, like this.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
That's it.
Cute, cute.
Thank you.
So, it's my live drawing.
On our live drawing.
It's an hour-long live drawing, so...
Good luck.
Yes, yes, yes.
I can't draw anything amazing.
No, it will be.
I just want to do my best.
And...
I think...
I want...
What?
I think I'm drawing upper body.
Because just one hour.
Sadly.
What?
Pose or facial...
Expose?
Expression.
Facial expression.
Expecto.
Expression.
Recently I went to Harry Potter cafe.
Really?
Before I go there, I will watch the movie again.
And repeat Harry Potter.
And what is good?
Facial expression.
I think...
I...
Honestly...
Sometimes I think...
Mint, why you using your face like that?
Don't you hear me?
Don't.
I think you...
You just...
I think you just cute.
But you using your face something ugly or something funny.
And something became...
Like...
Something...
I think...
There is...
There is mint?
What a face.
But...
Everything cute.
I think...
Emoji.
Emoji?
The emoji like...
That face...
And...
Yes, yes...
Okay.
Because I think about cute girls.
What to say?
I think that...
It's cute all the time.
I think like that.
But...
Mint-chan uses her face in a funny way, so look at that.
She says, you are a comedian.
The pressure is too much.
Why?
You are normally cute.
You are usually cute.
This is strange.
She is showing herself.
She is looking at herself.
She is looking at the mirror.
She is looking at the monitor.
She is cute.
Even if she is normal, she is cute.
Normally means...
Everything means cute.
Cute and funny.
I like your humor.
But sometimes...
But it's funny.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I always think about...
Mint is really good at using your character and your resource.
There is really...
I think you have talent.
Ah!
Yeah.
I love you.
I love you forever.
Yes.
And what pressure...
Oh.
Expression.
Something cute.
Or wink.
Or something...
A little snickering.
A little...
Hmm.
Something...
What...
What is your...
Normal?
Maybe...
Maybe the chat can decide.
Because they will be the ones watching the picture.
Watching you draw.
So...
Chat, what kind of face would you like to see Ayami sensei draw with me?
What?
Are you going to leave it to me?
You are a pain in the ass.
That face...
That's a little...
Don't say it's a bad face.
Ah.
Oh...
Can I draw a face?
Can I?
Do you want to draw it?
I want to draw it.
It's okay.
I will ask the staff or the people of Anime Central to ask Ayami again.
What are you doing, Ayami?
I'm sorry.
It's Japanese culture, Japanese culture.
That's right.
Japanese culture is not...
Japanese culture...
Oh, not reading the third term.
Understand!
He calls it freedom!
Oh, you say freedom!
Freedom!
Yes, I believe it works good.
I saw maybe... smog?
Smog is...
Try it.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Your mouth is like a cat.
I think you are very cute when you do that.
Ah, I don't like it.
I don't like it.
Ah, how is it?
How is your face?
Ah, how is your face?
How is it?
Ah, that's right.
It's always like that.
I look at everyone from below.
Ah, no, I look from above.
I hate you guys.
I hate you, but you came here today.
Ah.
Maybe that's also good.
Do you like me?
Smog is also good.
Smog, yes.
Smog and smog are two...
Wink is also good.
Yes, Wink is good.
But...
Ah, I was saying earlier...
I'm talking about mint using her face.
Something... something...
Something different.
You can say it.
Say it properly.
It's a smog.
She's using her face every time, everywhere.
Because I'm thinking about something...
I was thinking about something...
Maid.
Mint maid.
Yes.
You maid.
Maid.
And something...
Smog face is...
You maid.
When you using smog face?
Ojousama.
Gojousama.
When do you use smog face?
At the meeting?
Thank you.
I'll come again.
That's it.
Something different.
Yes.
When you take a break.
Ah, that's right.
When you take a break, you go back and say, I'm tired.
I'm tired.
That's right.
It's cute no matter what you draw.
But, as I asked you, Why I've been asking to you what facial is good?
Because just cute or just smiling is...
I think you don't like that.
So, you...
I think you like something funny things or something.
Funny things.
Maybe.
I want to know what is good.
Oh, maybe, maybe.
As I thought.
Smiling face.
Oh, yes.
Let's make a smiling face.
Okay.
Good luck.
Ah, don't get arrested.
Okay.
Try.
Just face.
Not all.
Okay.
Is okay.
I think.
Like this.
Freedom.
No...
freedom.
Just freedom.
Yes.
There is freedom to express myself.
Freedom to express.
What do you mean by freedom?
There are some expressions.
For example, when I write on Twitter that I am an idiot, that is a free expression.
Like, please forgive me.
You can't be that free.
I am sorry.
Not freedom.
I am so sorry.
Sorry, everybody.
That's right.
That's not freedom.
It's not that you are too free.
Freedom and such...
American culture is different from that of Japan and Asia.
So I haven't really thought about that.
Because, I mean...
This time, first...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We are America.
America, yeah!
Oh, yeah.
I think...
I mean, naked and walk.
Park.
Why naked?
Freedom.
That's not it?
You are too free.
But, is there such a thing?
If you are naked, can you be caught?
Yes.
Then...
Why are you surprised?
That's not enough.
Really?
Why?
Eh?
Just, I mean, want to showing...
And...
Naked...
That is...
Boo-boo.
That's boo-boo.
Eh?
Hmm...
Maybe America needs to be more free.
Ah...
Okay.
Don't try, don't try.
Eh...
You mean to...
Ah...
I'm...
I'm sorry...
For...
All the questions.
Because...
Just one hour drawing and...
Ah...
I think...
Hmm...
I might...
Only draw...
Ah...
I go.
You...
You are...
That is okay.
Just...
No face.
Just boo-boo.
Drawing.
How about that?
Oh...
Not bad.
It's good.
Freedom.
Everyone is happy.
Everyone.
Yes.
Everybody loves Ayami Sensei Erohon.
So...
That's right.
I'm sure you will be happy.
Oh my god,
that would be my honor.
I mean,
naked and bring naked mean to dakimakura and walk around the park.
We are both naked.
We are okay.
Okay, it can be a fan meeting.
Naked in the park.
Oh, but I need everyone naked too.
Yeah, everybody naked too.
Naked, yeah, and we got party.
We party naked in the park.
Yeah, and campfire too.
Oh, with your books.
Burn my books.
Burn my books and goods, merch.
And your clothes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We are not court.
No, no.
Mean to not call me.
I think I'm busy.
Yeah, time.
Sorry, sorry.
Oh, yeah.
That's how it is.
Okay, mean to.
Really thank you design permission I can join you.
That is really exciting because this is first join USA event.
And first time I think about what drawing is good for USA fans.
And I'm really think about.
For so many things.
But Ayami is really mean to use huge big opai pen.
And I really want to drawing you.
And Ayami asking to you.
Can I drawing you?
That I mean to.
My feeling is mean to.
Huh?
What?
No, no, no, no.
Mean to.
Huh?
Why?
Eh, eh, eh, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary.
I think she got scared.
No.
When I talk to.
I want to drawing you opai.
No.
I think if my face, scary.
But if my opai, it's okay.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm just drawing opai.
Okay.
I think.
I'm please looking forward.
To my live drawing session.
I'm really scary.
Because sometimes I'm streaming my channel.
I'm drawing, live drawing.
But that time, no one show.
Of course, no one showing real Ayami.
But this time, real Ayami sitting table and drawing.
Wow.
It's a rare chance, everybody.
Rare chance.
What chance?
Naked Ayami watching?
No.
Don't worry.
I'm wearing.
Will you be naked?
I'm wearing panty.
Don't worry.
Only panty.
And her new bra.
Yeah.
I can hide using my opai, long opai.
I don't need panty, maybe.
Oh.
Use my body.
Okay.
Good, good, good.
Wow.
I think.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Maybe no one, maybe no one will come.
Maybe no one will come.
Wow.
That's what I'm waiting for.
Yeah.
Yes.
Please wear your clothes properly.
I'm wearing something.
Don't worry.
And really nervous.
And also please wear something too.
I'm really scary because I'm really nervous.
And maybe?
Maybe?
Asumi?
Failed?
Drawing?
Why?
Maybe?
Too nervous and my hand not moving.
Cannot moving.
No moving.
And I mean.
So, so sorry.
No.
Session closed.
So sorry.
Bye bye.
Everybody.
No.
Everybody will say.
Ganbare.
Ayami-sensei.
You can do it.
Please.
Please cheer me on.
Yeah.
They'll cheer you on.
Right.
Everybody.
Everybody will cheer you on.
Yeah.
I mean.
I mean practice in airplane.
Ten hour.
Ten hour practice.
Please sleep.
And I want to drawing cute mint in anime center.
If you guys someone come anime center, please come and please check.
Yes.
Really.
Ayami drawing.
Yes.
Mint oppai.
Or.
Ahegao.
Ahegao or something.
Something.
It's a surprise.
Yeah.
Please check.
Will it be oppai?
Will it be ahegao?
It's a surprise.
After drawing, I mean arrest or not.
Please check.
That's the, that's the finale.
Wow.
What is good finale?
Arrest is.
Arrest is a good finale.
Yeah.
Hahaha.
There is a reason, legendary finale.
Yeah.
Maybe a first time ever.
Hahaha.
And then Sankai at the jail.
Oh, so sorry.
But that is funny.
Oh.
But don't worry guys.
I'm wearing some, some clothes.
Yeah.
I'm drawing cute mint.
Please looking forward.
And, and...
Eh, Soreji!
Eh, when, when you coming?
Japan?
Uh, June.
Oh, June?
Okay.
I'm waiting.
Yeah.
Uh, you, maybe you bring my birthday present.
Yes.
Hahaha.
Naked.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Naked mint.
Mint, okay.
My birthday present.
Naked mint.
Perfect.
Hahaha.
A gun?
Perfect.
You want a gun?
Gun.
Gun?
Hahaha.
Can you bring to Japan?
I'll be arrested next.
Oh, mint arrest.
Oh.
We write letter.
In jail.
I mean, American jail.
Mint, Japan jail.
And we write letter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really miss you.
Hahaha.
I wish, I wish, I was eating candy.
You're getting too poor.
Oh, ah, I'm really looking forward.
Oh, yeah, June, you come in.
Do something.
Ayami, do you, what kind of, what kind of, wait, at Anime Central, are you accepting gifts?
Oh, ah, yes, yes, yes, yes.
What kind of candy?
What kind of?
Oh, I mean, like.
Sour candy.
Oh, me too, me too.
Sour gummy.
Oh, sour gummy, sour gummy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, I mean, can eat everything, almost.
And bring it every, everything.
Okay, bring everything.
Yeah, yeah, no trashy, no trashy.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Oh, no trashy, okay, and just bring smart, smart.
Just one...
What is that?
Chupa chups.
Is that English?
Yes, English, English.
Ah, sorry.
I just thought it was English, sorry.
Chupa chups.
Just one is really happy.
Bring it.
I want to taste every, every taste, everything, every kind of.
Oh.
And bring money.
Dollar!
Please give me a dollar!
The plane is a little...
The plane is a little expensive.
Really.
Please marry me!
Marry me!
Please!
Someone.
Thank you.
Ayami is also looking for a husband.
Boyfriends, line up.
Yeah, please.
Please showing your house.
Oh, yes!
If you get to autograph, you can show your house and how much you make.
That's right.
I think watching this stream, Mint fans and Ayami fans think about, wow, absolutely Ayami crazy.
That's the best!
They went crazy.
Well, this time, because I'm really some high.
I'm a little excited and I'm having a lot of fun.
I think it's okay to do it freely.
Because until now, I was a girlfriend.
Every time, I'm just the only girlfriend to my fans.
I think Ayami will go to USA and I my feeling is something free.
She's getting too excited, you guys.
Yeah, and get married or divorce or go to jail.
Everything is okay.
Yeah, experience.
This time.
It's American experience.
Yeah, that is really cool.
I believe.
I will write some books.
One book.
America experience title.
And I will write book in jail.
Maybe.
Not bad, not bad.
It will become a Netflix show.
Maybe I can get money.
Maybe.
Royalty, please.
Yeah.
Good idea.
Okay.
So, Friday.
Friday.
Drawing after autograph session.
So, first you have an autograph and then you're drawing.
And Saturday.
Saturday.
Vtuber stream.
And Sunday.
I have an autograph session one more.
That is my schedule.
Come on, guys.
You have a whole weekend with Ayami-sensei.
And this time I'm really busy and my cat is sick.
Really sick.
He needs surgery.
Really?
And my mom come to my Tokyo house and take care to Kuma-chan when Ayami go to America time.
And this time my heart is really not good.
Sad Ayami because the vet doctor say maybe poo dying.
And I'm really crying everyday.
Strong, strong mind Ayami.
We can do it.
And I'm cannot drawing this time.
Mint some goods or posters.
And maybe next time I can chance to join another or Chicago anime event.
Yeah.
I want to drawing mint.
And I want to make mint goods.
And I want to make naked mint Takimakura.
I'll let you.
Thank you.
I'll give you It's my treasure.
And I really want chance to next time.
I hope that you have so much fun.
I'm so sorry about your cat.
But I think you will have so much fun and it will be a good distraction.
Yeah.
And you will have many, many fans who will be so excited to see you.
I saw your autograph sessions.
Both of them were full.
Yes.
Are you okay?
I'm nervous.
Maybe.
Some guy.
Some boyfriend.
Propose.
And maybe a a a shoot.
Shoot maybe.
I need that jacket.
What is that jacket?
It's not a life jacket.
It's like a protect jacket.
Straight jacket.
I need that because my boyfriend just shot at me.
Maybe.
No, no, no.
He's so cute everybody.
Don't say that.
I said it.
It's very cute.
Yeah.
Ah.
Last week, I went to Akihabara.
And Starbucks.
And I'm sitting Same seat.
You sitting seat.
Nice.
English.
Please explain in English.
Okay.
Last week, Ayami went to Akihabara.
And we met last time at a Starbucks.
Yeah.
And she sat in the seat that I sat in.
I'm stalker.
Sorry.
Did you sniff it?
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Oh.
Good smell.
And Ayami drink drink some mango drink.
I'm stalker.
It's okay.
Me too.
I stalked you to the cafe.
Ayami cafe.
Yeah.
I saw Ayami figure.
I was like I saw panties.
Don't do that.
Dabi.
White panties.
Cute.
Yeah.
It's rare to see panties.
I'm sorry.
Psycho.
Thank you.
I want to see you soon.
I really want to see you soon.
Yeah.
Soon.
When I come to Japan.
Yeah.
I want to take shower with you.
Okay.
We go to onsen.
Oh.
Really?
We can.
So.
All of you.
Both men and women.
No.
Men.
Two of you.
It's private.
A private onsen.
Small one.
Okay.
I'm looking forward to it.
I'll do my best.
I'm looking for a really small onsen.
The smallest one in Japan.
Yeah.
The smallest onsen.
And we can't go in together.
That kind of place.
We can go in together.
Yes.
That kind of place.
I'm not a pervert.
No.
Okay.
Just love each other.
Yes.
That's right.
Everyone.
I want you to give up on Mint-chan.
It's my thing.
It's a little weird to say it here.
I'm sorry.
You guys.
Mint already mine.
So sorry.
Then what about your boyfriends?
My boyfriend is boyfriend.
You girlfriend.
What's different?
Girlfriend.
Girlfriend take shower together.
Boyfriend no touch.
I'm platonic.
Platonic.
Don't touch.
No touch.
Social distance, please.
Social distance, everybody.
Yeah.
Please.
Sorry.
Your boyfriend is lonely.
I can't help it.
Even though it's your boyfriend.
But...
The really important thing is...
Not body.
Body.
Not body, I think.
Mental.
Emotion.
Love each other.
Truly is really important.
True.
Body.
Touch.
And something, something.
That is just...
No, no, no.
Too simple.
Sorry, everybody.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm waiting.
True, true, true, true love.
Oh, true love.
And I'm finally found.
Found.
Where?
Here.
Oh, oh.
Thank you.
It was very fun.
Thank you for inviting.
Thank you.
And please love Mint forever.
And please a little like Ayami too.
And please looking forward Anime Central.
And please looking forward Mint future too.
Thank you.
But she's mine.
Give up her.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you guys.
Mint hates you guys.
Get out of here.
This is our...
Yeah, yeah.
Go away.
Social distance.
Go home.
Go to Anime Central.
Yeah.
Not here.
Anime Central.
Yeah, not here.
Wow, you're so cool.
Wow, sexy.
Oh, wow.
Thank you everybody for watching.
Look forward to Ayami Sensei drawing me at Anime Central.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Yippee.
And please subscribe to Ayami's channel and follow on Twitter and buy everything at Anime Central so that there's no fire and are you eating my hair?
Ah, so sorry.
What flavor is it?
Mint flavor.
Mint taste.
It's like a toothpaste.
Yes, some...
Some...
No, no, it's okay.
Because some... when?
Two years ago, I'm using... trying to using some... what is that name?
Coal... Coal...
13C and something gate.
Like gate.
Coal... Oh, coal gate.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Toothpaste, you know?
Yes, yes.
That time, I'm using some mint...
taste.
That is... not bad.
It's the same taste?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, good.
Make a shower.
Go away.
Take shower.
Yeah, okay.
Brush, brush, brush.
Tooth.
What is that?
Brush your teeth.
Yeah.
Kiss each other.
You guys.
Yeah, you guys kiss each other.
Not us.
Kiss each other.
No, no.
I need packing time.
I want to go.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
We have to leave.
Get out of here.
Yeah, get out of here.
Yeah, come on.
We're trying to...
We're busy.
Go away.
I'm really busy.
I'm packing and go to the airport.
And I'm finally alive.
Departure?
Departure is departing.
Chicago.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody.
Love you.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Okay,
bye. Bye.